what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup series
our weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors and all the tidbits that
you may have missed over the course of
the week
and for those of you guys who are huge
fans of dc's and justice gods among us
and who are looking forward to the young
avengers in the mcu
do we have news for you but make sure
you guys stay tuned at the end because
that's what we'll cover it so
opening up our episode this week john
watts has been
brought in as the director of the
fantastic four film
and i gotta admit i'm excited about this
if you guys wanna see
an interview that i did with john watts
that is incredibly cringy
check out the video down in the
description
it's the video that i did over comics
explain where i interviewed tom holland
and
jake gyllenhaal and samuel jackson and
all those guys from spider-man far from
home
it was a really cringy interview with
john watts but it was interesting
nonetheless so
make sure you guys go check it out but
i'm excited about this john watts has
done a
great job on the spider-man films and i
feel like he'll translate well to the
fantastic four
i mean if i really want to be like crazy
theories and all that kind of stuff
spider-man and the solo series and moa
comics when he first appeared originally
tried to join the fantastic four
and was ultimately shot down later on in
jonathan hickman's run
he was inducted into the future
foundation so i think it'd be kind of
cool if john watts has like some
post-credit scene in spider-man no way
home where peter parker is
cordially invited to join the future
foundation which is brought to you by
reed richards great way to introduce a
fantastic four
i don't know if that's gonna happen but
it would be a cool little little tidbit
a cool little easter egg to go on in
there having said that
i have full faith that john watts is
gonna be able to make a great fantastic
four movie he's handled spider-man
spectacularly up to this point
no pun intended so i fully believe that
he is going to be able to do the same
thing with a fantastic four
but continuing our discussion on movie
news but
deviating away from the marvel cinematic
universe anna torv has been cast as tess
and the last of us series now for those
of you guys who don't know who anna
twarf
is she was in fringe and fringe was a
modern day take on the x-files as far as
i'm concerned
i know it has like a huge core fan base
but i feel like
that's basically what it was but it was
basically a sci-fi show and in reality
while i won't say that fringe matches
the last of us
as a one-to-one ratio it's pretty damn
close dealing with all kinds of crazy
conspiracies and alien infections and
different things along those lines
so having somebody that moves from a
series like that into something like the
last of us
i think is a great choice having said
that i'm curious to see how they're
going to handle tests
obviously the show is not going to be a
one-to-one of the video game at least i
hope it's not
i hope it incorporates a lot of the
prime elements but hopefully it's not
going to be a direct comparison not only
that
i've always wanted to know more about
the backstory of tess and so i'm curious
to see what they end up doing with their
character but regardless
not a whole lot of news here just
thought it's kind of cool to see a
character from a sci-fi
show being brought in to the last of us
series and i'm excited for it so i
really jump at any little bit of news
that we get
but continuing our discussion here on
video games two big things have happened
one of which is kind of a small little
reveal that's been given to us but it's
super exciting
and the other one's terrible so the
first thing is that we are getting a
remake of dead space
yes i'm so excited about that i love
that space oh my god i love that video
game series
scared the hell out of me but i loved it
i absolutely loved dead space and i
can't wait to be isaac again i loved all
that stuff but
dead space for those of you guys who
never played it it's one of the best
science fiction horror games ever
released it's it's
fantastic the storytelling is wonderful
wasn't the biggest fan of the second one
not nearly as big of a fan as the second
one as i was of the first one
but they were still great games
nonetheless the third one was garbage so
much so that everybody pretends it
doesn't exist
so they only say it's only two dead
space games
i'm really hoping they don't give us
that terrible story of the third game
but
dead space one and two were wonderful
the first one takes place in space
the second one actually takes place on a
space station
earth i keep wanting to say it's earth
but i believe it's a space station but
things pop off you guys remember like
when you're going through like all the
apartments and all that kind of stuff
like you're walking through there
and there's one room where like a baby's
crying and the whole time you're like oh
my god i really hope that little baby is
not going to get killed by like the
monsters and everything but you kind of
know it's going to like
it's pretty wild it's really really wild
but the games were wonderful they were
spectacular there aren't really any
details in terms of the quality of the
game
any additional footage or anything along
those lines but because it's going to be
a remake we can largely assume
it's going to have increased graphic
fidelity right so it's going to look a
lot better
on the next gen consoles probably a pc
release and all that kind of stuff but
regardless it's going to be great i'm
excited for that
but the second thing that we were going
to talk about here which is a disastrous
piece of news
amazon is killing people's gpus and it
kind of makes sense it's killing their
livelihoods might as well kill their
gpus too
so apparently what's going on here is
amazon had the beta release of their new
world mmo
and people who were spending probably in
excess of two thousand dollars on rtx
3090s because
you know scalpers uh they're dying their
gpus are getting fried
like literally just bricking these
things apparently it's happening worse
to the evga 3090 for the win models than
they are
any other models but it's not just 30
90s people with like 30 80 ti
30 80s all kinds of people are basically
reporting and saying their their gpus
are being killed by this game
i was watching some gameplay footage it
doesn't look overly intensive
in terms of graphics so maybe it's just
because of the youtube video that i
watched but
it looks like an upscale version of like
world of warcraft you know what i mean
but the graphics don't look like a giant
mmo version of like destiny 2
right or or something like final fantasy
15 that's like an
mmo game it doesn't look like it's
exceedingly hardcore
in terms of graphics so what apparently
is being reported
is that people's gpus are running at 100
and that's what's killing them
but to me it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense because people stress test their
gpus at 100 all the time
and they do it for hours on end to make
sure that like their overclocking is
working or whatever the case happens to
be so
i don't really know what's going on
regardless amazon responded by saying
they're issuing a patch and they're
advising people to basically decrease
their frame rates and to max them out
at 60 which is pissing off all the
people who were on 144 hertz monitors
i don't know what to tell you apparently
like if you're running 144 hertz
it's killing your gpu i don't
necessarily know all the details and
everything but the important thing is
amazon's responding with a patch and
apparently it's supposed to fix the
problem if not at the very least
cope with the problem until they can
find an actual solution but that's the
reason why we have betas it's so that
these kind of things can get sorted out
i doubt that anybody who signed up for
the beta was expecting their two
thousand dollar gpu to get fried
but nonetheless this is why we have
betas but moving back into the marvel
cinematic universe
michaela cole has been cast for a
mystery role in black panther too
now for those of you guys who don't know
michaela cole is fantastic the i may
destroy you series on hbo i absolutely
loved it but she wrote and did all that
stuff
like she's literally the mastermind
behind it but people are really
speculating
what her mystery role is and a lot of
people are thinking that it's storm now
the reason why a lot of people are
speculating that this
is storm is because in reginald hudlin's
run in black panther volume 4 issue
15 you actually ended up learning that
in her early years when she lived in
africa
storm had a romantic relationship with
t'challa now ultimately they had to end
it because t'challa's duties as king
required him to focus on that and storm
you know just couldn't maintain the
relationship with him
years later they would actually get
married and probably one of the most
celebrated comics of all time
which actually took place during civil
war but the whole thing behind this
is that there's a lot of history there
and so a lot of people are hoping that's
the case now at the time that i'm
recording this
i have not heard of any news that's come
out and debunked the theory
that it might be storm but a lot of
people are hoping that this is how the
x-men get introduced into the marvel
cinematic universe
that is just small little things here
and there that you basically
having some kind of reference to
colossus as part of like the winter
guard and black widow
of course we didn't get that but that
storm might appear in black panther too
as basically being a potential romantic
interest of t'challa she maybe attends
the funeral of t'challa assuming they
have it to reflect the unfortunate
passing of chadwick boseman here in the
real world
and when people ask who are you she says
my name is aurora
and then boom you've got storm in the
marvel cinematic universe we don't
really know
exactly what's going on with her
character but regardless i tweeted this
out yesterday and i'm curious to see
what y'all's response is on this
i think black panther 2 will actually
outperform avengers in game
at the domestic box office just because
of the fact that a lot of people
really want to see how black panther 2
is going to be handled
in the aftermath of chadwick boseman's
passing i don't really mean to turn into
a thing where it's like a cash grab or
anything like that that's just kind of
my thought right because the passing of
chadwick boseman is a huge deal
and he was fantastic as black panther
and i think a lot of people just really
want to see what it's going to look like
after but regardless
i'm excited to see who michaela cole is
gonna play
in the the new black panther film i
don't really know but it's gonna be cool
and i'm looking forward to it and so
getting into our final two pieces of
news here the young avengers and dc's
and justice gods among us
a lot of you guys who are huge fans of
injustice will be happy to know
that it's getting a movie and i've been
screaming about this for a long long
time
i loved injustice gods among us those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
this i'll give you the quick little run
down here
essentially what happens is superman
finds out that lois lane's pregnant with
her kit
she ends up going out on a mission where
there was just some kind of crazy event
that took place in the docks or
something like that
she's kidnapped by the joker she's taken
to a tanker the entire justice league
hunts around for
ultimately superman finds her first at
the same time all that's happening
the fear toxin of the scarecrow was
taken a nuclear warhead's taken
and some kryptonites taken come to find
out what had happened is the joker and
harley quinn had kidnapped lois lane
they took her to the tanker they laced
the entire area with a kryptonite dust
that included the fear toxin of the
scarecrow
which forced superman to hallucinate
that lois lane
was doomsday in turn he basically freaks
out grabs what he thinks is doomsday
takes her into space the whole time
batman's trying to get a hold of
superman
when he finally does he tells superman
that's not doomsday
that's lois lane so basically the joker
tricked superman into killing his own
wife an unborn child
the other part of this is that the
nuclear bomb was set inside of
metropolis
and was set to detonate when lois lane's
heartbeat stopped so when superman
killed lois lane
he blew up metropolis at the same time
batman grabs a joker takes him back to a
police station
superman comes flying through like a bat
out of hell smashes through all the
shield constructs like the green lantern
puts in place to try to stop him
flies into the into the police station
and basically punches a hole through the
joker just like kills the joker on the
spot
after that he's just like enough and
just becomes like this this like
dictator over the world
it's amazing it's one of the best
stories ever in the history of comics
i love injustice gods among us i really
hope they do what they did with the dark
knight returns where they give us like
two parts
honestly i feel like the dark knight
returns didn't need to be two parts i
feel like they focus too much on the
mutants and that didn't really need to
happen but
hardcore purists will say that it needed
to be two movies so they could basically
do the entirety of the story
in absolute detail don't really know if
i agree with that but the whole point
here
is that this is one of the coolest
movies that you're ever going to see
from the dc comics universe from warner
brothers animated
which also kind of reminds me i don't
know why warner brothers doesn't just
focus on their animated movies maybe
because people look at animated movies
and see them as kind of silly
and a little bit childish i don't really
know why they love going to movie
theaters and watching movies about how a
guy is exposed to gamma radiation and
turns into a giant green rage monster
not really sure how you split the
difference i mean at the end of the day
if you can call the avengers movie
a comic book movie that's awesome i
don't know why you can't do the same
thing for animated films
after all the lion king's the greatest
animated film of all time and nobody
calls that silly or childish but i
really wish that warner brothers would
just
focus on their comic book animated line
and just leave the live action movies in
the dust because they have just been
bad consistently but the animated movies
have been great consistently i wish they
would just focus on that but regardless
dc's gods among us is going to be an
awesome film and i cannot
wait for this movie to come out having
said that moving into our last bit of
news here focusing on the young avengers
actor jack veal who played kid loki in
the loki tv show
was recently asked about what his
thoughts were in appearing in the young
avengers and what he basically revealed
is he has not heard anything about it
yet now
that does not mean it's not going to
happen and it does not mean he's not
going to be in it
we know young avengers is going to
happen it's only a matter of time but we
also know that paul bettany
and elizabeth olsen were basically hit
up at the 11th hour to see if they
wanted to do a one division tv show like
literally it was like a napkin idea and
they just launched it right so
it's one of these things where if the
the marvel cinematic universe and disney
are keeping this really close to the
vest
these guys won't even notice a project
until right before it launches and so
even if they do know they've probably
been sworn to secrecy under pain of
death
and they can't tell us but regardless of
the situation
i do want to see jack veal and the young
avengers as kid loki
i think he'd be a perfect addition to
the marvel cinematic universe as a
greater whole
and in all honesty i think that's one of
the things you're going to see in a lot
of the shows going forward right you're
going to see the introduction of
characters here and there
that marvel's basically going to kind of
throw to us and say hey like what do you
guys think about this character what do
you think about that character
not so much in terms of hitting it on
the nose and asking us directly
but by just kind of revealing them to us
over the course of the shows and seeing
how we respond
in terms of our our whole position on
social media for example
there was a whole argument that took
place between whether or not the loki
alligator that we saw was either an
alligator or a crocodile
there was this huge debate that was
happening on twitter it was just it was
explosive everybody was just kind of
going back and forth
over whether it was an alligator or
crocodile but regardless that kind of
stuff right there is really what helps
to determine
what characters are the most popular and
which ones aren't and so because of that
i feel like
having jack veal as kid loki and young
avengers would be great it'd be a great
addition to the young avengers landscape
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section but regardless
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace